l'inflation qui affaiblit les
collectivités locales et qui tapent
aussi le portefeuille des Français avec
la nécessité pour les plus précaires de
se rendre au resto du coeur ou dans des
épiceries solidaires elles permettent de
faire des courses pour seulement 10% du
prix de vente en magasin un sacré coup
de pouce pour les familles comme à jouer
les tours ou c'est rendu Aurélie Renaud
rue Pasteur les clients ont pris
rendez-vous pour faire leurs courses à
l'épicerie solidaire fruits légumes
épiceries salées et sucrées produits
d'hygiène les bénéficiaires ont accès à
l'épicerie après un suivi par une
assistante sociale
204 il y a quatre personnes au foyer
donc bah elle a le droit à temps pour
pouvoir tout en sachant que bon bien sûr
c'est pas vendu au prix du commerce
c'est vendu voilà donc on a une base
tarifaire et on va entre 10 et 15% du
prix du Commercy katia a 50 ans elle
élève seule son fils de 13 ans elle est
en recherche d'emploi et ses dépenses
sont plus importantes que ces ressources
Katia fréquente l'épicerie sociale
depuis deux mois elle y obtient une aide
pour remplir son réfrigérateur mais
également un soutien moral ben moi je
peux pas faire de courses en dehors
finalement comme je suis déjà tous les
mois je suis à découvert d'un certain
somme donc du coup non non je paye que
3,50 € ici et on a on repart avec des
sacs plein ça m'aide aussi avoir
personne dans les mêmes difficultés
finalement donc
moralement ça aide les stocks
proviennent de la mairie de
Joué-lès-Tours les dons viennent aussi
de la Banque alimentaire mais ils sont
de moins en moins nombreux en effet la
Banque alimentaire a de plus en plus de
bénéficiaires l'épicerie étant en bout
de chaîne elle doit trouver d'autres
solutions pour remplir ses étals
l'option faire participer les commerces
locaux comme ceux du centre-ville je
sais pas il leur reste 5 kg de tomates
il me dit non demain ça n'ira plus voilà
est-ce que vous venez les chercher donc
il faudrait qu'on ait un système comme
ça donc ça c'est à l'étude normalement
ça devrait se mettre en place assez
rapidement ce jour-là 34 personnes ont
pu remplir leurs sac de course des
achats à prix symboliques pour nourrir
une centaine de personnes sur deux ou
trois jours
merci